so teach what are the test results Teddy
you my friend are dyslexic
you also have dyscalculia that's what I
got
we're not done you also have a
processing disorder I got a touch of
prostate cancer she didn't touch my ass
one time boy welcome to night school
we need to cramp four years of high
school into a semester I think his mama
breastfed him being a Jew prestige in
the conventional way just isn't gonna
get it done why we in ring with the
square root of 81
what 81 this woman is a brick wall you
either pass the midterm or you out of my
class what I'm still tested you want to
explain to me how you got a perfect boy
I know I didn't get a perfect score
because I missed a few on purpose
snitches are [ __ ] what I'm going to
work come to get you chicken from the
Lord
petty they suit you got on its dermis
hey I am where I'm supposed to be at a
fast food point next to a strip club
rusty in the right spot I can smell
cocoa butter and fried chicken at the
same time
you can get on my way be ready to get
started I'm not playing with you with
the capital Belgian waffles you starting
to force my hand
water is comprised of rain you got it
right Betty what is that smell
now that's a gas you bust ass in my face
it's in my mouth you got my lips off
you